vergesst Spaghetti Eis das hier ist
Pancake Pasta dafür machen wir erstmal
einen Standard Pancake Teig Mehl Zucker
Backpulver und Salz verrühren
separat Milch ein Ei und mit
geschmolzener Butter verquirlen und
jetzt kombinieren wir beides und jetzt
füllen wir unseren Teig in eine
quetschflasche
alright Pfanne heiß machen und eine
kleine Spirale machen eine zweite und
jetzt gut aufpassen kurz abdecken paar
Sekunden warten und wir nehmen unsere
Spaghetti legen Sie in unseren Teller
und Backen uns noch ein paar mehr hier
sind unsere fertigen Pancakes Spaghetti
jetzt brauchen wir noch ein bisschen
Soße wie beim Spaghetti Eis Erdbeersoße
das Beste was es überhaupt gibt oh junge
das wird so lecker und ein bisschen
Parmesan ackerarbeiter Schokolade wow
guckt euch das bitte an
es sieht wirklich gut aus aber wie
schmeckt das